alors on a fait un classement des 50
meilleures blagues
regardez vous allez voir de la 50 yens à
la 46e place et je crois un philippe que
tu es très très bien classé donc savoir
regarder de la 50e à la 46e c'est parti
[Musique]
la bonne soeur aller dans un taxi c'est
une très belle ville et par direct
assuré le show en taxi et ailleurs dans
le rétro il n'arrive pas dévisser son
regard de cette bonne soeur qui est
d'une beauté incroyable et je me sens à
personne dit elle dit que si ce poste
vous vous regardez plus dans le rétro
que que devant vous on va avoir un
accident et dit non c'est pas ça mais si
vous êtes tellement belle t mon mon
fantasme à moi ce serait un jour
d'embrasser une bonne soeur
si belle que vous et vos services
d'écouté ya pas de problème si vous êtes
croyant il part est célibataire mais dit
je suis croyant je suis croyant je suis
célibataire des animaux garez-vous sur
le côté hier ce côté l'outil bosses
derrière et lui roule une gamelle mais
ton ferme et non ça va jamais en nombre
à c'est tout huit doigts sa langue sur
les yeux dans les crocs donné par te
gaver incroyable heroes monde à bayonne
wissam et après il se met à pleurer
c'est en conduisant il est là il
sanglote rsa dit mais qu'est ce qui vous
a rédigé sans bloc parce que je suis un
gros menteur je suis pas croyant je suis
marié je suis mayer a servi ses bagages
moi je m'appelle raymond chauveau qu'un
nouvel
[Applaudissements]
c'est un mec qui rend dans un bistrot il
fait bon jour monsieur su combien le
coca petit buffet 6,5 euros
il fait rien de moins qu'au cas le
barman il fait donner moins dix euros
sinon on va voir ludique c'est 5 euros
fessé 5 rôles coca synchro le service à
un accord voilà 10 euros le barman
durant cinq ans il fait pourquoi vous -
des cinq ans qui fait ce que j pas de
coca serbe est qu'il arrive on l'appelle
audi vient ta femme à la coucher il
arrive en courant la clinique et grant
hill ou au niveau physique et attendez
attendez faut qu'on vous dise un truc
le chirurgien l'arrivée du faut que je
te parle ton fils l'aîné mais il n'a pas
de bras et comment l apave rabat elle
n'a pas de bras les décembre à l'espace
pas grave on va l'aimer quand même
eva pour aller dans ce sens mais bientôt
temps c'est pas fini qui n'a pas de
jambes et commence une madeleine c'est
quoi là par exemple
bon ben si c'est pas grave je l'aimé
quand même si mon premier enfant je peux
rien faire et quantité mais attendez
c'est pas fini a dit quoi lilas paquet
[Rires]
rentrez vous allez voir lui rentrer
c'était culotté une ong du nord et du
boss pas l'algérie d'aimer et prend
l'aurait dit je t'aime office à 10,1
parler il est sourd
un mec sort de chez lui un matin pour
aller travailler
il ya un type qui est en bas de chez lui
et qui en le voyant pas sans lui fait
cocu qu'aucune match 6 mai suivant
pardon je suis fait cocu cocu et une
formule soit pas bien mais que des sent
le mec le suit larry fait cocu cocu le
mec des 100 francs le métro le mec monde
dans la même rame que lui et de loin lui
fait cocu cocu mec devient dingue
il ya jusqu'à son bureau comme ça ils
bossent le soir qui redescend à 18h le
même éclat d'un il fait ça cocu mais ne
répond pas il fait cocu cocu cocu
millions de plus en plus fort le mec
dans le métro par le mexique en face
cocu mek rentrer chez lui dit ah ce
fameux ya un truc que je trouve quand
même assez étrange et un mec qui m'a
suivi toute la journée qui m'a traité de
con qu elle fait et bailly se trouve ça
bizarre tu as rien à venir feu non
monsieur était pas bien non ça va ça
vient dégénérés qui traite de cocu dans
la rue ça va être de ma fautif énorme
enfin un effet énorme ça va fewell enfin
quand même je fais un bon mec va se
coucher le matin il se réveille il a
bossé il ya le même mec qui fait cocu
coca et rapporteur en plus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un haram qui se dit tranquille que
c'est un arabe qui arrive qui arrive au
quartier à il acheté ma dernière
maserati malaria tue deux fois la mode
et oui 3 son pote sont patents renault 5
son plan renault 5 descend de la voiture
du rattachement maserati et lui dit je
t'échange maru no 5 contre ta maserati
et en plus je rajoute cette lampe le
petit organe gilbert tu vas pas match à
voir l'accueil comme ça je m'en fous de
talent que moi j'ai une maserati sur le
net à renault 5
u10 nommé regarda temps il frotte sur la
langue comme ça il ya un génie qui sort
est idiot génie génie fait nous du thé
le génie sans une théière comme c'est
leur fait deux verres de thé higuain est
choqué et oui du hockey tu cherches des
demandes maserati fille donne moi ta
renault 5 et l'allant évident car on ne
s'inquiète avant qu'il arrive devant
chez lui il est content et klaxons
klaxons klaxons sa femme et soeurs elle
voit son mari avec une renault 5 1
comprend pas dit mais qu'est ce qui se
passe et où elle où la voiture est tous
les dix ans montrent inquiètes montrent
inquiètes dont sa femme et monde dans la
rue sur et où il frotte la lampe le
génie sort idiot génie un génie donne un
gros gros sacs de bijoux à ma femme le
génie regarded yan'an désolé moi je sais
faire que du thé
[Rires]